das Güterschiff Erklärung am Steuer
eigener Leo Doms früh morgens ist der
48-Jährige unterwegs auf dem völkerack
in den Niederlanden
immer wieder wird es eng für die
Binnenschiffe in der erfolgreichschleuse
muss Leo Dom seinen Frachter direkt
neben ein Tankschiff manövrieren durch
das enge zusammenrücken können bei einer
Schleusung möglichst viele Schiffe
mitgenommen werden
sondern
wenn man so kein gute Überblick wie weit
man von der Seite ist und in die Kamera
kann man fast auf 10 cm gucken
und auch bei der Ausfahrt ist Timing und
Feingefühl gefragt dabei muss die
frachttermin genau am Ziel ankommen mit
135 Metern Länge und über 11 Metern
Breite gehört die Erklärung zu den
größeren güterschiffen wegen des
ukrainekriegs und des Niedrigwassers auf
dem Rhein pendelt sie fast nonstop
zwischen den Seehäfen in Holland und
Belgien und Süddeutschland doch in
Antwerpen verzögert sich diesmal die
Beladung Leo Doms nutzt die Zeit für
Wartungsarbeiten vieles macht der Aigner
des gut 4 Millionen Euro teures selbst
Elektrik manchmal ein bisschen Schweizer
auch oder besonderes man muss alles ein
bisschen können nichts gut aber alles
ein bisschen
es gibt immer was zu tun an Bord
tägliche Routine für Matrose Chris
schleifen und Streichen der schiffslag
soll die Erklärung vor Wind und Wetter
schützen
das ist aber sehr schöne blinkt uns so
dass ich eigentlich nur Spaß das ist
schön aussieht aber vor der Schiefer ist
wichtig dass es nicht der wann immer das
Wetter ist zulässt geht der ewige Kampf
gegen den Rost weiter wirklich frei hat
man an Bord eines binnenschiffs nie seit
der 15 Jahre alt ist fährt Leo Doms mit
Binnenschiffen durch Europa seine Frau
Marei ist mit an Bord oft erfahren die
beiden erst am Vortag wohin und mit
welcher Fracht die nächste Reise geht
dann müssen sie innerhalb eines
bestimmten Zeitfensters ankommen ihre
Arbeitstage sind lang
und auch wenn man auf der Couch sitzt ob
man guckt Fernsehen bis man noch immer
im Kopf vielleicht muss ich morgen dann
das machen also ja
über die 100 Stunde in Woche aber ich
weiß nicht da muss man ja
sieben Tage und dann noch ein paar
Stunden was anderes machen
heute steht z.B auch die Wartung der
Luftfilter der beiden schiffsmaschinen
an die archero wird von zwei 12 Zylinder
Dieselmotoren mit jeweils über 1000 PS
angetrieben die steuerbordmaschine
springt bei diesem Testlauf etwas
verzögert an ein Problem dass diese
Reise später noch verkomplizieren wird
dann geht es zum Ladeplatz im Seehafen
Antwerpen
Leo Doms soll innerhalb von vier Tagen
nach Ludwigshafen fahren die Fracht
Ammoniumsulfat ein ungefährliches Pulver
für die düngemittelproduktion doch die
Erklärung kann nur ein Drittel ihrer
Kapazität laden sonst würde sie zu tief
im Wasser liegen und könnte wegen des
Niedrigwassers auf dem Rhein auf Grund
laufen
[Musik]
für zwei 1.250 also noch knapp knapp 300
Tonne noch Sensoren im Schiff zeigen an
wie die Ladung verteilt ist die
Erklärung soll möglichst gleichmäßig im
Wasser liegen weil sich der ladetermin
um einen Tag verschoben hat ist Leo Doms
jetzt später dran
aber das schaffen
am Montagabend
[Musik]
Richtung deutsche Grenze einrichten
fahren musste und ja danach und dann
Richtung Dinge und dann schaffe ich das
am Montag auf nach Lübben
nach vier Stunden Beladung und einem
Frachtraum der gerade mal zu einem
Drittel gefüllt ist beginnt die gut 620
km lange Reise nach Ludwigshafen
am nächsten Morgen Zeit fürs Frühstück
maria hat Proviant für zwei Wochen
gebunkert
[Musik]
jeden Morgen um 8 Uhr dann erst wieder
Frühstück und ja er Fahrt ich mache das
fertig und dann bringe ich das oben
und dann hat wir uns wahrscheinlich
hinfahren
die Tage an Bord verlaufen meist ähnlich
die beiden haben daher ihre Routinen
lieb gewonnen Frühstück Mittag und
Abendessen gibt es immer zu festen
Zeiten während der Fahrten auf der
Brücke die ist dann auch es und
Wohnzimmer
seit 23 Jahren ist mareia auch
Steuerfrau und lenkt das 135 Meter lange
Güterschiff Zeit für Leo etwas anderes
zu erledigen und es muss nicht immer
Büroarbeit sein
oder ihr macht das große Stück und dann
ich unter der Couch aber meistens macht
er das ja aber auch das selber
von Hand steuern muss man Reihe nicht
mehr oft die Erklärung ist vor dieser
Fahrt mit einem Autopiloten nachgerüstet
worden der lenkt nun das Güterschiff
entlang einer programmierten Route noch
ist das ungewohnt für marail vor allem
in Engstellen wie zum Beispiel dieser
Brücke
mir so muss meine Hand dabei ein anderes
und ich ertraue das noch nicht so ist
und das Schiff geht von selber aber die
andere Schiffe die die nicht vielleicht
nicht so
und gerade bei niedrig Wasser sind viele
Schiffe unterwegs weil dann die
Frachtmenge die sonst einschiff
transportieren könnte auf mehrere
verteilt werden muss dann wird
Frachtraum ein knappes Gut das treibt
die Transportpreise teils drastisch nach
oben gute Zeiten verbinden Schiffe doch
auch für sie steigen während des Ukraine
Krieges die Kosten zum Beispiel beim
Diesel den bekommt die Erklärung während
der Fahrt von einem bunkerschaft das
geht auf dem Rhein kurz vor der
deutschen Grenze links Seins Leo Matrose
Chris und auf der Brücke Maria sind ein
eingespieltes Team bei diesem Manöver
ich muss doch aufpassen dass alles gut
geht und gleichwelle die wieder los
machen sie muss viel langsamer machen
und wenn ihr auf Seite liegt schneller
machen
das bunker-schiff liefert auch mehrere
tausend Liter Trinkwasser
die werden als erstes in die Tanks der
Erklärung gepumpt
auf der anderen Seite kommt der Diesel
ins Schiff insgesamt 19.000 Liter hat
Leo Doms bestellt
Binnenschiffe fahren mit
steuerreduziertem Kraftstoff doch auch
der ist teurer geworden
ungefähr so vor 17.000 Euro
dreimal so teuer wie vor dem Ukraine
dabei wird die Erklärung nicht mal
vollgetankt Matrose Chris nimmt das mit
Humor
ich bin froh dass ich die Rechnung hier
nicht bezahlen muss
nach dem Tanken erreicht die Erklärung
Deutschland weiter geht es auf dem Rhein
die Reisegeschwindigkeit mit 1250 Tonnen
Ladung liegt bei rund 10
Stundenkilometern über Grund am zweiten
Tag der Reise geht es vorbei am größten
Binnenhafen der Welt Duisburg
vorne im Bug ist das Apartment der
Besatzung auf dieser Tour ist steuermann
der 46-Jährige fährt seit viereinhalb
Jahren auf der arkerung alle zwei Wochen
wechselt er sich mit einem Kollegen ab
beide haben ein eigenes Zimmer
das ist meine Kabine also eigentlich
mein Schlafzimmer hier schlafe ich auch
wirklich nur meistens bin ich im
Wohnzimmer
[Musik]
und dann haben wir ja noch ein ganz
nettes Badezimmer
mit Waschmaschine und Wäsche Trockner
Binnenschifffahrt und Familie sind eine
Herausforderung Chris Frau und seine
beiden Kinder sehen in zwei Wochen lang
gar nicht
aber es gibt ja Smartphones Internet und
SMS so habe ich jeden Tag mehrmals
Kontakt heutzutage ist das viel
einfacher also kein Problem
nach 14 Tagen an Bord ist Chris zwei
Wochen zu Hause seit Jahren arbeitet der
gelernte Fotograf als Matrose ist mit
Herz und Seele Binnenschiffe dabei
genießt er es vor allem die Städte zu
erkunden an denen die arkero festmachen
[Musik]
sehr oft an Wochenenden oder an freien
Tagen wenn wir abladen kann ich in
verschiedenen Häfen ohne Probleme von
Bord gehen da kann ich einkaufen Leute
treffen ein bisschen trinken spazieren
gehen oder Fahrradfahren
[Musik]
weiter geht die Fahrt nach Ludwigshafen
samstags vorbei an Düsseldorf und Köln
dann von 21 bis 8 Uhr macht die
Erklärung fest am nächsten Morgen will
Leo Doms von der Brücke aus die
Maschinen starten vergebens
die steuerbordmaschine springt nicht an
der letzte Maschinenausfall auf der
akero liegt die Jahre zurück damals war
es die backbordmaschine die Anlasser
mussten getauscht werden Leo Doms
befürchtet dass das gleiche Problem nun
die steuerbordmaschine lahmgelegt hat
ich bin jetzt nicht sicher ob das
Batterie ist oder oder stadtmotoren
und ja sonst weiß ich nicht sie muss
immer anrufen
weil die akiro 2 Motoren hat kann die
Fahrt immerhin weitergehen ob der
Schaden an Bord repariert werden kann
und wie schnell ist noch unklar ja wie
fahren wir jetzt mit rein und dann
später rufe ich mal die Mechaniker und
dann gucken wir was er sagt oder
überhaupt heute ist Sonntag also ich
hoffe der kann kommen mit einer Maschine
und deutlich höherem Kraftstoffverbrauch
geht es weiter Richtung Ludwigshafen Leo
verständigt die wochenendbereitschaft
einer niederländischen Werft um die
Maschine möglichst schnell wieder ans
Laufen zu bringen der Mechaniker kommt
doch das wird teuer
jetzt ja unser Verlust nehme und dann
reparieren und dann gucken
nach dreieinhalb Stunden Anfahrt kommt
der Mechaniker aus Holland nach
Andernach und geht an Bord
Fehlersuche die Elektronik funktioniert
nur teilweise der Bordcomputer ist an
doch die Anlasser drehen nicht ein
Schutzschalter arbeitet fehlerhaft und
eine Sicherung ist durchgebrannt für
beide Teile hat er Mechaniker Ersatz
mitgebracht kleine Ursache große Wirkung
die Kosten der Reparatur samt
Sonntagszuschlag belaufen sich auf
zweieinhalb Tausend Euro
hin und her fahre
Wichtigste ist dass er wieder läuft dass
ihr wieder weiter können mit zwei
Stunden Verzögerung kann es schließlich
weitergehen
mit beiden Maschinen und Zeitdruck eine
weitere Verzögerung am abladeort will
Leo auf jeden Fall vermeiden
ja dann ist schon schwierig
das Geld aber man muss ziemlich schnell
mit Maschine das kostet dann auch mehr
Sprit und dann ist er die 2 Stunde nicht
wegen der Kosten von der Sprit
eigentlich nicht
ja nicht gut aber lern mal gucken wir
haben auch nicht zu viel Tonne
hergeladen also das läuft so ziemlich
gut an vielleicht ist ja auch wieder
vorbei an Koblenz geht die Fahrt durch
das sogenannte Gebirge die Erklärung
fährt bis in die Nacht und macht bei
Bingen ihren letzten Zwischenstopp
am Montagmorgen dann bei Oestrich-Winkel
die entscheidende flachste Stelle des
Rheins Niedrigwasser der Grund warum die
Erklärung in Antwerpen nicht mehr
frachtladen konnte unter dem Schiff sind
hier gerade mal noch 60 cm Wasser Leo
Doms drosselt die Geschwindigkeit
mitnehme und dann guckt man immer
ob das dann erreicht zu fahren
nach insgesamt vier Tagen Fahrt kommt
die acero in Ludwigshafen an
mit jeder Schaufel verlassen 5 Tonnen
Ammoniumsulfat den Frachtraum bis das
Wetter schlechter wird fängt ein
bisschen
[Musik]
und da machen darf nicht werden mit
Ladung was
mit wetterrad mit Regen nicht gelöst
oder geladen wird dann hat man immer
Chance das ist Verzögerung gibt doch so
lange diese Ladung nicht gelöscht ist
kann Leo Doms keinen Folgeauftrag
annehmen das Wetter bestimmt den Alltag
der Binnenschiffer auch wenn wieder mehr
Wasser den Rhein hinunter fließt
[Musik]